[Music]
i'm chris harvey and i'm the chocolate
ta for and sons chocolates in beverly
hills california
and sons makes a variety of modern and
classic infections
probably our most popular flavors at
ansons are the speculus bonbon
the lemon verbena and yuzu bon bon one
of our signature bonbons is our hazelnut
praline and pop rock bonbon
[Music]
so the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to color the white chocolate
in this case we're going to use pink a
little bit more of a rose pink
and a blue piping a straight line is
very difficult and in fact this is
piping a straight line into a demosphere
and so i'm going to pipe the lines in
in a straight fashion but i'm going to
tilt the mold onto
a container to kind of hold it at that
angle
so now that our colors are in it's time
to spray the colored cocoa butter
into it in this case we're going to use
black
and we first have to temper it which is
taking it down to its working
temperature which is 29 degrees
centigrade
we can spray it into the molds
[Music]
the cocoa butter sets almost immediately
so we have to work very quickly
and after it's done spraying we're ready
to shell the molds
to shell the chocolate we take the
sprayed mold to the chocolate machine
we flood the cavities with the milk
chocolate
scrape off the excess vibrate it
to get any bubbles out of it so it all
falls into place
flip it over to empty the chocolate back
into the machine
and then we scrape it and clean up the
sides and now we're ready to fill it
the pop rock praline filling is a
mixture of hazelnut praline paste
hazelnut paste milk chocolate cocoa
butter and unflavored pop rocks
the pop rocks will be protected by the
fats so they won't start sizzling until
the guest eats it
so once the filling is made it's time to
pipe the center
into the shell and it's all done by hand
it's right at eye level
so they're all measured out correctly
it's about five grams of filling per
bonbon
after we fill the shell bonbon molds
it goes into the cooling cabinet for
about 35 or 40 minutes
[Music]
and then we're ready to put the backs on
it so we warm up the back side to allow
the tempered chocolate
to adhere to the already set chocolate
once chocolate is set
wet chocolate will not adhere to it
it'll pull right off it's allowing it to
kind of
marry together at this point we cap it
and we add our monogram logo transfer
sheet to it
we scrape off the excess chocolate and
now the bonbon mold is ready to go into
the cooler
after about 30 minutes we take it out of
the refrigerator we
invert it onto a board
and knock it on the back and they should
all release
and that is how we make our signature
praline pop rock bon bon and suns in
beverly hills california
one of the things i love about watching
our guests eat these
is the reaction on their face they love
that sizzle going on
it transports them sometimes to their
childhood
and for a new generation of chocolate
eaters it's a whole new experience
we never think it's too early to eat our
chocolate breakfast lunch dinner
chocolate makes people happy that's what
is great about chocolate it makes
everybody happy
[Music]
you